Hey look a duck he's not a duck that's a
rabbit
yeah can you turn the page Megan Markel
and Prince Harry giving us an extremely
rare look at Archie in action it's a
duck and he's about to eat a piece of
bread the page got the piece of bread
it's a rabbit and he's about to eat a
carrot let's go to the next page look
arch in the adorable clip which was
released on Archie's first birthday the
Duchess of Sussex reads her squirming
son the book duck rabbit for charity and
let's just say this kid has personality
in the video we see Archie laughing see
[Music]
we see him babbling oh great you scared
him away
here he is demanding another book but it
was a duck well anyway now what do you
want to do and his excitement at the end
is infectious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
duck rabbit we never see Harry in the
clip but it seems pretty safe to assume
that the male voice you hear belongs to
him and we're guessing he's on camera
duty
Megan sat down for this heartwarming
story time video with her son to help
with save the children's save with
stories campaign the organization shared
it on Instagram revealing in the caption
that Megan's video is helping to raise
urgent funds for our coronavirus appeal
as for Archie's review of the book he
thinks it's tasty Archie is by all
accounts a very happy and joyful little
boy and he's now moved Holmes twice of
course from the UK to Canada and then
from Canada to LA and apparently he has
adapted really well to use surroundings
as long as he's with his his mommy and
his daddy he is a happy little boy and
you know that the couple clearly just
absolutely dote on him and royal expert
Katie Nichol tells us at one-year-old
Archie is on the go I'm told he's not
walking just yet and he's in that
cruising stage and pulling himself up
onto anything that he can and he's a
very determined boy who's trying his
hardest to walk and probably to say a
few words as well but happy confident
and a very joyful little voice of course
his May sixth birthday happens to fall
in the middle of the corona virus
pandemic which definitely impacted any
celebrations Megan and Harry might have
been planning their take very seriously
so maybe I'll just say that it's you
know it will be very it will be very
low-key this would have been an
opportunity to have had Dorian friends
over that first sort of gathering in LA
but that won't be happening okay so no
party but what about a sibling for
Archie at the moment they really are
just being gentle with themselves they
are taking time for themselves they are
enjoying time being together as a family
I think there's every hope that at some
point this year we will have
it's the announcement they clearly want
a sibling a little brother or a little
sister for Archie but you know let's
just give them a bit of time because
it's been a whirlwind for everyone but
it's particularly being a rollercoaster
for Megan and Harry
[Music]